let's have a hard question i mean a hard
conversation if if facebook just allows
everything won't it go nuts
like isn't it possible we'll see crazy
extremism and crazy groups of people
just screaming
violence or whatever i mean actually
look at anti-fun look at look at black
lives matter violence 140 plus days of
rioting
yeah and then isn't it because they
won't check them they won't say
stop advocating for violence yeah i
think
i think there's a potential i mean if if
there's some changes with facebook and
more things are
i mean if in general more things are
allowed and it's funny
because the left always claims that the
facebook's not doing enough to censor
hate speech
when there's a bunch of people on the
list that are right wing but there's
nobody on the left
uh even segregationists on the left
they're never on the list but
um yeah i think there's a lot of crazy
stuff on the internet i mean
i think we're barely even beginning to
grasp like how influential the internet
is how powerful it's become
in the last 20 years we've seen this
technology revolution so
i don't think even the leading
technologists or even the people who
created the internet
understand what it's become um so i mean
that goes into the larger debate of
what's allowed on the internet i mean
yeah there's gonna be crazy there's
gonna be a lot of crazy stuff on the
left and the right
both both parts do you think there is
some kind of collusion between
democratic politicians and facebook
100 you do think so yeah um
because well i mean so here let me say
this
indirectly at the very least at the most
direct collusion so i mean did you ever
witness uh a democratic politician
coming in and talking with anybody or
any or any kind of uh
evidence that they were i do not have
direct evidence
um what i can say is there's a group of
about six people
so i talked to one of my my team manager
um alexis
and her she had conversations
interactions with
the global policy team at facebook
there's about six people to determine
the policy
and she and she was telling me like yeah
like they're all kind of
they all kind of have the same mindset
and they're all based in san francisco
as far as direct like you know collusion
with democrat politicians
um i talked to a journalist with the new
york post the other day
one or two days ago and he was finding
this connection between
twitter executives who had this
revolving door with the obama
administration well so there was a
facebook employee who joined joe biden's
team and
a twitter employee who did as well and i
think the guy's name is andy stone i'm
not sure
okay facebook communications previously
worked for the democratic congressional
campaign committee
so we've seen that there is the
revolving door between facebook and
democrats
and twitter and democrats they're
working for joe biden yeah this
this guy announced uh that they were
going to censor the new york post story
and hunter biden
like that that's crazy i mean this is a
prominent american newspaper started by
alexander hamilton in 1801
and he's i believe was 1801 and he's
like well we're going to censor the
story anyway this guy worked for the
democrats
apparently i guess he worked for barbara
boxer before so uh
what makes you uh look i get it we have
those stories
but uh uh you know based on your
experience working with this company
what what made you think that there was
potentially direct collusion
uh as far as direct collusion i mean
like look i didn't work in the
facebook offices in menlo park um
so i interacted with some you know
the people i interact with were mainly
cognizant employees
to be frank now sean browder is the
person who interacted with
constantly with the client with facebook
and so what i can you know notice what
i've noticed from my conversations with
him
is you know first of all he's very he's
very left-leaning bernie sanders
supporter
um they are very interested in you know
me bringing up trends about right-wing
extremism uh like boogaloo and
for example the virginia gun rally in
january was labeled as like hey watch
out for hate speech or
you know racist groups and you know at
this virginia gun rally
um so i mean the evidence i have
is not really you know it's not like i
had conversations with facebook
um employees who said yes the democrat a
democrat politician
um told us to change the policy
um so i think there's more of an
indirect effect from
from all these leftist organizations um
so just more of like an extreme bias
yeah more of extreme bias i mean
are there politicians they're probably
buddy buddy with people at facebook i'm
sure there are i mean
i mean we had joshua fourstein get uh
get banned like a month ago or whatever
and the only way he could
you know get get his account back was by
reaching out to trump officials like
people he knew
so so like if that's happening on that
side let's just you know
the same thing's probably happening on
the opposite end i mean if
people are probably you know getting
giving favors or or helping out democrat
politicians
um i did notice here's something huge
that i do have evidence of
is the something called the the shields
that peop that they have that facebook
has
so it's called the fire brigade um
let me see if i have the notes on here
but basically
anyways basically there's different
shields so i ran across some content i
tried to like action it and it was like
you cannot action this content there is
a shield on this content
so fire brigade stands for like pr fire
so there's different tags so there's
like high pry
x check tag and business tag so you
cannot delete or touch
certain content because it has this
shield or tag associated with it
so it may very well be that there's
accounts that
you know should be protected kind of
like vips that you cannot delete
interesting i ran the same thing when i
worked at uber because there was we
would deal with
uh fraud and partner fraud but we
occasionally run the vip accounts like
really
big celebs that we didn't want to piss
off or have their account
cancelled or something so so we we
seeing everything we've seen over the
past
year you know someone like uh myself i
read the news all day and i have my
opinions on whether or not trump's going
to win but with your experience with how
big tech is manipulating
the elections essentially do you think
trump is going to win
i think that trump has a good chance of
winning
i think facebook's doing everything they
can to
like push people a certain way um
there was a there was a cartoon image of
trump shooting himself
and facebook said we're gonna allow that
there was a
who was the guy who tried to assassinate
reagan you know is he kind of
got out of jail or out of the hospital
hinckley
yeah something like that yeah and so he
came out of the hospital and there was
this meme implying that he should shoot
trump
and facebook allowed that wow and so
yeah i really think there's a chance
that
that you know despite all that there's a
good chance trump will still win
especially when you're going against
someone like joe biden i wonder if it's
not despite all that i wonder it's
because of it
i wonder if people are sick and tired of
seeing the psychotic
behavior of the left the cancer culture
stuff like
you don't see videos of people you know
threatening joe biden you don't see
these pictures or videos mocking them
i have to imagine there's regular people
who might see like remember remember
when kathy griffin held up the head
yeah i wonder how many votes trump trump
got from that from people who are just
like oh that's disgusting what's
wrong with you you know and then all of
a sudden kind of just like i don't like
these people
you know i think it's backfired yeah i
think you're right in a lot of regards i
think it's backfired because there's so
much hate against trump
that the normal individual who's not
hateful is like hey why is there all
why is all this hate against trump and
so yeah i think that's very possible uh
there's been pushback
and it's kind of worked against them and
the fact that i revealed this
damaged you know facebook's reputation
and brought to light certain things
so excuse me if facebook had been
playing by the rules from the get-go
then i wouldn't have been able to film
their discrepancies them breaking their
own rules
can't facebook just be like oh no this
is this is cognizant these these
oh darn it these evil contractors we had
no idea
well some of the posts uh they can't
really argue that because for example
when they took they told us to not treat
abortion as a violent death
it said the facebook team has given us
said the fb team has given us guidance
to not treat abortion as a violent death
that reminds me of my conversation with
jack dorsey
when i was explaining to them that their
rules are inherently biased
and you know vagina god and dorsey were
immediately like oh no that's not true
what are you talking about and i said
you have a misgendering policy
like you should say if you misgender
someone if you went to a conservative
and said
don't misgender someone they would
assume you're saying if someone is born
male then you call him he him and
born female you know she her whereas
twitter's perspective is the inverse
if if if somebody says their identity is
you know then you gotta use that
so so to a conservative what dorsev uses
misgender ring it's
it's it's inverted and if their rules uh
rules are
are built around a progressive
understanding of these definitions what
they mean
then yeah they're inherently biased yeah
yeah because like
and you can't really tell that your bias
if you're they're that biased you can't
tell it that you're biased
and there's that that group think effect
that we saw you know in 2008 when
when uh the media just found over
president obama
but an example that related misgendering
is we had uh so in the hate speech
policy if you're attacking someone
like a race or an ethnicity and you have
like a stick figure that represents them
then that can still violate so if you
have a little cartoon imagery of a
christian
figure like a little stick figure
kicking a kicking a muslim
stick figure out of europe that violates
the hate speech policy
because they're representing the stick
figures are representing that
characteristic the ethnicity of the race
and so with um with uh
mental okay so with gender so there was
a meme
that showed the the that was calling
certain
genders and mental illness so i think it
was like non-binary or something like
that he was saying
and it said this is a mental illness but
there was no stick figure it was just
the symbols
so it's purely talking about the
ideology
so facebook backtracked because for a
while they're like okay allow it does
not violate our policy
but then they backtrack and they said
actually we're going to delete this we
know it does not violate the policy
but we're going to delete this so once
again
more exceptions um i have you know a
list of like 30 examples here but
um bro it's human centipede yeah it's
huge
these bernie bros are getting news from
progressive websites
and these writers are getting their news
from facebook posts
yeah and then it's all being recycled
over and over again
you know twitter is probably one of the
worst things that ever happened to
journalism
because it created a feedback loop among
journalists where they just follow each
other and share the same stories over
and over again
and facebook's algorithm essentially
promoting intersectionality because it's
got more keywords more buzzwords and
it's shot content
so long as they allow it it will
continue to get worse so here's here's
what i think happens
people on these people on facebook
accidentally got sucked into this vortex
yeah where content that was about police
brutality and intersectionality
was socially acceptable because racism
bad
and it combined all these keywords so it
made money and that was the perfect
storm
these people were reading stuff on
facebook believed it all then got hired
at companies to moderate and said oh but
these things are true i see them all the
time
that's okay and then the journalists see
the same thing and write the stories and
create this feedback loop where they're
all
spinning away in their little human
centipede vortex off in the corner while
regular people are confused
what is going on yeah because regular
people aren't
in that world that's the craziest thing
to me is that
like joe biden struggling
struggling to find that space between
regular america and the democrats is
just it's not there
and that's why he's trapped in this
fracking thing so you watch the debate
yeah watch the debate
the reason joe biden lied and said we're
gonna ban fracking is because the
activist left is in that vortex with
these people at facebook with these
journalists
and they believe insane things and
they're a tiny group of people
relatively so joe biden if he wants to
be the democratic nominee
you got to say the craziest thing
imaginable and that's why even bernie
was like going off the rails and their
policies kept getting crazier
yeah then once biden won now he's got to
talk to regular america again
and so he's like no i don't want to buy
fracking and they're like here's a video
of you saying it over and over again so
i can't imagine him winning
he chased so here's what i'm hoping
here's my optimism
i think you've got the desperate
democrats
chasing after twitter the twitter audi
left who are in this human centipede
vortex
and it's going to backfire on them
because regular people don't live there
regular people don't know what joe
biden's on or talking about when he says
these things
and i think that's why they're so
desperate you know to run i think
they're
i think they're running against trump
like anti-trump
joe biden is not the candidate the
candidate is do you like trump or hate
trump
yeah and they're doing that because joe
biden can't possibly please the
democrats
they are split up in a million different
ways and they'll never get back the
moderates in fact
the party seems to be shrinking
shrinking based on gallup
gallup's latest polling yeah that
they've they've their the party
affiliation for democrats has gone way
down
so we'll see how that plays out i guess
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
i mean
uh you know facebook's been involved in
in the elections they they've
certainly taken a central role and um
it's weird because i saw this this app i
have for where you get like discount on
your gasoline it's called like get
upside
and i saw this little notification that
popped up and disappear it's like hey if
you vote we'll give you 10 cents off per
gallon i'm like
i'm gonna take that to the attorney
general yeah arizona same thing like
with like slotsky's if
if you they can't offer you uh sandwich
shop yeah i'm familiar with they offered
money someone a while back like they
were
offering a free sandwich if you bring in
your voted sticker which violates
arizona law yeah yeah so that's my big
my biggest complaint is like
this is so good it's such a good
sandwich they really should give you a
free sandwich they should change this
yeah so that's my thing is like you know
if
sloshies are getting can you get in
trouble for that look what facebook's
doing on a global scale
i was moderating content in latin
america and venezuela
in mexico the mexican presidential
election i saw some
you know content about spain facebook
has training decks
for poland for taiwan for like every
country imaginable
like in poland they freaking like
facebook shut down their
like their independence they march every
year because they call it like hate
speech
so the amount of and they've they're
always purging these like nationalist
groups in in spain or in europe
and so i just think that you know the
the amount of power they have and
influence they have is immense and
they're using
all of it to try to influence this
election in the name of
you know protecting against hate speech
it's a feedback loop
and it's going to implode at some point
because the things they believe
are getting more and more unhinged and
and it it literally doesn't make sense
yeah
like when you see the degree to which
i'll i'll i'll put it this way
ocasio-cortez
gets 400 000 concurrent viewers on her
her twitch
stream yeah i heard about that this is
the future of politicians dude
this this this woman with all due
respect i i respect that she was she was
a bartender and she
it's it's part of the american dream you
know that anybody can be
a politician it's it's for oven by the
people so you're gonna be the smartest
person in the world you'll kind of be
rich
and that's pretty incredible but man
does she not know anything about what
she's doing
the bills that she's gotten passed have
been like renaming post offices
and yet she still gets all of these
leftists screaming and cheering for her
and i i so i was talking to my friend
this guy i know earlier
there's a viral post by sophia norwicz
of all of these leftist blue checks
mocking trump for saying coyotes were
bringing kids over the border
coyote of course is the name of the
smugglers who bring
people across the border yeah all of
these people
thought that trump was literally talking
about coyotes carrying children
like modingo you know or the the dingo
my baby or whatever
it was a combination of ignorance and
arrogance and then when i see aoc
and i see you're getting 400 000 twitch
stream viewers i'm just like
our politicians of the future it's going
to be idiocracy they're going to be
influencers
who know nothing but man can they get
those views
because she she won her primary she's
she's she might not win reelection she
probably
probably will you know because there are
still republicans and
maybe i really doubt it she's going to
win and that's crazy because what has
she done
other than rename some post offices and
then offer up ridiculous policies
no she's an influencer she's got 10
million she's got 10 million followers
on twitter
sure that's part of being an influencer
dance and she and she dances
and you take someone who has no idea
what's going on you put
we are going to have politicians who are
literally going to have flame wars on
twitter and that's going to be at no
policy discussion well
they should have a term limit then in
and out if you don't do anything too bad
do something with your time don't waste
my time
i don't think that's the issue i think
the issue is
people don't vote based on policy
they're voting based on orange men bad
they're they're voting based on who i
like or don't like that's how reagan got
in too
he was famous he was a b-list actor but
but right but
what was reagan running against in 84.
do you know john bush senior
was it mundell mondale it was like a
horrible campaign
yeah and and what we've seen with nixon
as well is that there are these
when things go too far left does snap
back so maybe
we're secretly going to see this big
trump wave and everyone's going to be
shocked and the polls are going to be
wrong but what i kind of see happening
in the future is
the left is being wound up into this
psychotic space
and it's so insane that policy can never
be argued
that's why they're running joe biden and
that's why he hides in the basement
because if joe biden comes out they're
going to be like wait a minute i
disagree with that so better just hide
him
and then say you hate trump though right
the politic the politicians we're going
to have in the future are going to be
people who are like
i have no idea policy but man left
woo and they're going to be like yeah
left and it's going to be literal try
to make teams well it's like the hunger
games movie uh with pan am and and uh
katniss everdeen
uh seriously what was the name of
lawrence the actress uh jennifer
lawrence
for lawrence yeah and you know you have
pan am you have cornelius snow and and
they
they're always they're having like
non-stop parties in the capital they
have no clue what's going on in the rest
of the country exactly
and then uh and then they celebrate you
know people dying
right and competing against you know
killing each other
in a barbaric fashion thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you